Bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
Estados Unidos se enfrenta la peor
crisis de salud pública del Siglo 21
según los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades en el año
2021 se registraron más de 107.000
muertes por sobredosis en el país de las
cuales un 66% se debe al consumo de
fentanilo El fentanilo es un opioides
sintético 50 veces más fuerte que la
heroína y 100 veces más potente que la
morfina resulta especialmente peligroso
porque va directamente a la sangre y una
dosis muy pequeña puede ser mortal la
corresponsal de Francia
es la autora de este reportaje que
veremos a continuación y que muestra una
radiografía sobre la situación del
consumo de opioides y opacios en Estados
Unidos y como algunos proyectos en Nueva
York se han enfocado en prevenir la
sobredosis y disminuir el consumo en la
vía pública
mamen se encuentra con nosotros hoy Hola
mamen hablemos un poco más de reporteros
qué tan preocupante es la cifra de
consumo de fentanilo en Estados Unidos
[Música]
Buenas tardes compañeros pues es muy
preocupante como decías está detrás del
66% de las muertes por sobredosis y
también es muy preocupante sus efectos
pensad que deja muy adormilados a los
consumidores por eso lo llaman la droga
zombie de hecho en este reportaje en el
que hemos entrevistado a muchos
consumidores Ellos nos confiesan que no
quieren consumir fentanilo pero este es
el principal problema que la mayoría de
la gente no sabe que lo está consumiendo
porque a lo que hacen los carteles es
camuflarlo entre la heroína y la cocaína
Por qué Porque se trata de como decías
de un opioide sintético que es muy
barato de producir con lo cual es mucho
más productivo para los cárteles y por
eso las dosis de drogas están vendiendo
más barata a 5 dólares el principal
problema es como decía que no se puede
detectar y que con una dosis muy pequeña
de fentanilo puedes conseguir el mismo
efecto que con una dosis normal de
heroína cuál es el problema que esta
dosis es que esta droga es letal para
que se hagan una idea solamente
miligramos que son 15 granos de sal
literalmente pueden ser letales además
las autoridades están muy preocupadas
porque la última moda en fentanilo que
está llegando según la DEA la agencia de
narcóticos estadounidenses de los
carteles mexicanos son fentanilo en
forma de pastillas de colores y
diferentes formas para atraer al público
más joven y eso sí que es preocupante sí
mamen Y qué están haciendo las
autoridades para contrarrestar las
muertes por sobredosis
si las autoridades armenias se han dado
cuenta de que es imposible controlar
toda la mercancía que esté llegando a la
calle Así que se han Aliado con las
asociaciones con los bares y con las
discotecas por ejemplo aquí en Nueva
York se han abierto dos centros de
consumo de droga controlado lo llaman
son unos espacios que están trabajando
con la policía y con el ayuntamiento en
el que los consumidores pueden ir a
consumir valga la redundancia su propia
droga y ellos les proveen de toda la
parafernalia digamos necesaria para este
consumo Qué pasa que en caso de que haya
una sobredosis lo pueden frenar a tiempo
porque como digo son centros de consumo
controlado de hecho desde que abrieron
sus puertas el año pasado hasta hoy han
conseguido salvar a 400 personas que
Podrían haber muerto de sobredosis más
ideas que se están extendiendo en el
país unas tiras que son como una especie
de prueba para que nuestros espectadores
hagan una idea como las pruebas de covid
para detectar si una droga tiene o no
tiene fentanilos están distribuyendo
discotecas de muchas ciudades en este
país y aquí en Nueva York la situación
están crítica han aumentado un 14% las
muertes por sobredosis desde el año
pasado que el ayuntamiento está
empezando a repartir un medicamento que
se llama naloxona que se trata de un
medicamento de administración nasal que
permite revertir una sobredosis Gracias
mamen aquí la historia
[Música]
estamos a las afueras de Filadelfia en
el barrio de Kensington
es el epicentro de la peor crisis de
salud pública que enfrenta al país
Honestamente te rompe el corazón hoy
acompañamos a Melanie trabaja aquí de
voluntaria está acostumbrada a esta
imagen
Melanie conoce perfectamente esta parte
de Ciudad delfia hace un año era ella
quien consumía heroína en estas calles
voy allí con un propósito nunca iría
sola sabes saliendo o a pasar el rato
pero voy allí con mi equipo tenemos un
objetivo
su meta es conseguir que otros
dependientes de las drogas Reagan su
vida como lo ha hecho ella por eso cada
semana viene con su equipo para ayudar a
decenas de personas adictas que se han
quedado atrapadas aquí
tenemos gente que ha donado calcetines
Estos son kits de reducción de daños y
tienen torniquetes jeringas toallitas de
alcohol es para ayudar a detener que se
extiendan enfermedades Y eso Por
utilizar agujas sucias y demás traen
mascarillas un pequeño botiquín e
incluso el material necesario para
revertir una sobredosis y salvar una
vida narkan es lo que utilizamos para
revertir una sobredosis se administra
por la nariz
saben que el equipo de Melanie cuida de
ellos en un lugar donde no es fácil
sobrevivir
cómo es este barrio Es peligroso es
terrible disparos apuñalamientos gente
que muere y otra gente que quiere
robarle sus cosas incluso durante el día
Ese es mi novio nos conocimos cuando
nuestras familias Se mudaron cerca a la
una de la otra
has estado siete años limpia Qué pasó
vine aquí por mi novio y vine y solo
acabe entrando en esto yo solo por qué
no lo sé no estaba pensando era
fontanero tenía un gran trabajo y se
lastimó la espalda le recetaron
pastillas sí lo pusieron en tratamiento
de pastillas para quitarle el dolor el
dolor era insoportable y cuando en el
2012 le retiraron la prescripción de
calmantes Álex recurrió a la heroína una
transición que según los expertos como
el doctor Daniel sader es muy común y
tiene su origen en los años 90
el origen realmente comenzó aumentando
las prescripciones de oxicontine para
mitigar el dolor y fue impulsado por los
médicos tras la adecuada publicidad por
parte de la compañía por DIU El oxy es
el nombre comercial de la oxicodona
y de legal utilizado para reducir el
dolor se extrae de la misma planta que
la heroína por lo que su riesgo de
adicción es similar eso no es una
sorpresa pero Igualmente la
promocionaron y también los doctores
como si no hubiera riesgo de adicción el
medicamento ontin incluso había superado
los controles de la fda la agencia de
medicamentos estadounidense pero a
principios del año 2000 los expertos se
dan cuenta de que son miles las personas
dependientes de estas nuevas pastillas
es Entonces cuando aumentan los
controles por parte del gobierno
la gente se enganchó a estas pastillas
que todavía estaban disponibles en la
calle pero sin tantas recetas como antes
y entonces empezaron a comprar heroína
el motivo de ese cambio Es que la
heroína es un opioide que funciona de
manera similar a la oxicodona y además
es mucho más barata con miles de
personas adictas en las calles entra en
juego el fentanilo una droga 50 veces
más potente que la heroína por lo que se
consiguen más dosis con menos mercancía
pero ahora solo hay algo de heroína y
mucho fentanilo en la mezcla y lo están
cortando con otras cosas como
tranquilizantes para animales o
bicarbonato de sodio aún así el
fentanilo está detrás del 65% de las
muertes por sobredosis en este país y
las cifras son cada vez peores en el año
2012 12.000 personas murieron por el
consumo de droga en 2015 son alrededor
de 52.000 Cuando llega la pandemia en el
2020 las cifras se disparan
termina el día y se regresa a casa
Melanie es la manager de una de las
casas de savages de recovery una
asociación sin fines de lucro que
proporciona ayude vivienda a personas
que quieren dejar las drogas a un lado
que es todo esto
tenemos una lista de compra en Amazon y
la gente ordena cosas y nos lo manda
Melanie comparte casa con cuatro jóvenes
más que también tratan de superar su
adicción estos son los planes de todos
de la semana pero el camino hasta aquí
No ha sido fácil
con 16 años se volvió adicta a la
oxicodona
tengo mucha suerte de que me haya
apoyado tanto después de todo esto
Melanie cayó en la adicción a las
pastillas siguiendo los pasos de su
novio a finales de los 90s se
prescribían tanto que llegó un momento
que cualquier persona podía conseguirlas
y lo siguiente fue que dependía de ellas
físicamente Y a partir de ahí que
pastillas comencé con oxicon la
comprábamos en la calle y luego el
gobierno paró las prescripciones de
pastillas que eran tan fácil de
conseguir y ya Solo fue una progresión
natural pasará la heroína
de los calmantes pasó a consumir heroína
por 10 años se sometió a 17 tratamientos
de desintoxicación y estuvo cuatro meses
en prisión por el uso de drogas en la
vía pública me obligaron a estar sobria
y no te dan nada Sabes medicamentos ni
nada así que solo puedes quedarte ahí y
pasar por ello
fueron dos semanas en las que solo
estuve tirada en mi celda de la cárcel
en mi propio vómito y sabes no fue un
buen momento y te hace ver esto como
es esto lo que quiero que sea mi vida
entrar y salir de la cárcel el resto de
mi vida Y sabes cumplir los 30 en
prisión Y pensé esto no es lo que quiero
para mí
Este es mi esposa
el pasteurellín también dedica sus días
a los habitantes del barrio de
Kensington vive en esta iglesia que en
verano acoge a estudiantes que vienen de
otros estados y buscan un campamento
religioso
nada los muchachos están teniendo su
devocional antes de salir de aquí estos
son los paquetitos que vamos a dar allá
en la comunidad
contiene un poquito de todo y la Toyota
para que así se puedan limpiar
este grupo de jóvenes de entre 11 y 12
años viene a ayudar a los más
necesitados tienen dos monitores que les
guiarán en su primer día voy a orar
antes que salimos de aquí
volvemos al barrio de Kensington esta
vez con música
eulen Confía en su efecto terapéutico
con ella avisa a todos de que él y su
equipo pasearan por el barrio durante
esta mañana para ayudar a quienes lo
necesiten
[Música]
lo que vamos a hacer ahora es repartir
estos paquetes
[Música]
Cuántos de ustedes están un poco
preocupados eso está bien No hay nada de
malo en ello mientras se eulen
tranquiliza a los jóvenes conocemos a
John tiene 23 años se te ha caído
Por qué comenzaste a consumir drogas
sufría abusos sexuales de hombres
mujeres
madre lo permitió era
stripper nos dejaba a mí y a mi hermana
solos en casa Así que eran o sus amigos
o gente diferente quien abusaba de mí
sexualmente y ella lo sabía John duerme
cada día en estas calles con su novia
Desde hace dos años ella también es
adicta a las drogas ambos comenzaron a
usarlas para tapar el dolor de los
abusos a los que eran sometidos por sus
madres
sí comencé por las pastillas por qué
Para huir del dolor si solo para escapar
su madre era alcohólica y abusaba de
ella durante su infancia tu madre era
alcohólica y tú solo quería subir sí
como muchos otros aquí acabaron
cambiando las pastillas por la heroína
empujan en este carrito todo lo que
tienen el resto se lo robaron mientras
dormían
reconocen que sueñan con una vida mejor
pero su adicción es más fuerte y el
destino siempre acaba de volviéndolos a
este mismo lugar
mientras ellos consumen y dejan un
rastro de jeringuillas el ayuntamiento
trata de limpiar la zona pero es
imposible
cada día amanece igual
un problema que en Nueva York combate
con este nuevo proyecto la ciudad acaba
de abrir los dos primeros centros de
consumo de estupefacientes controlados
todos son artículos limpios que
necesitas para consumir drogas
todo lo que me estás viendo tomar aquí
todo se queda aquí
usas jeringas de 27 centímetros cúbicos
y medio
Este es un espacio limpio donde los
usuarios tienen todo lo que necesitan
para consumir de manera segura los
narcóticos que ellos mismos traen de la
calle cuántos años tienes 49 Cuánto
tiempo llevas consumiendo drogas comencé
con la marihuana cuando tenía 13
PSP y cocaína cuando tenía 17
y empecé a esnifar heroínas 1993 a la
edad de 20
entonces cuatro años más tarde comencé a
inyectarme
aquí el objetivo es prevenir la
sobredosis frenar las muertes y evitar
que aumente el número de infecciones por
SIDA además de acabar con el consumo la
vía pública cómo te sientes me siento
bien Ahora
Jason es voluntario desde hace tres años
lo primero que pasa cuando
vienen alguien al programa de sobre el
centro de prevenir a los sobredosis
tiene que enrolar el programa nosotros
hacemos una pregunta para ver qué es lo
que ellos van a usar cuando entran y
cómo lo van a usar cualquier cosa que
pase aquí tenemos todo lo que se
necesita para responder a un sobredosis
este equipo ha salvado más de 400 vidas
en los últimos ocho meses
en una ciudad donde cada año mueren dos
mil personas por sobredosis al frente
del proyecto está Sam su mayor logro Es
que la policía se ha convertido en un
gran Aliado ellos Ven a los oficiales
entrando para conocer acerca de lo que
estamos haciendo Y cómo lo hacemos así
que imagínate Imagínate que estás en un
edificio un espacio de hecho en un
centro para consumir drogas y los
oficiales entran en la habitación
conmigo ellos no se preocupan porque
saben que no les va a pasar nada
ahora su plan es llegar a todas las
ciudades para evitar que imágenes como
estas se apoderen del país en lo que
muchos consideran la peor epidemia del
siglo XXI
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para visualizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima